Kevin!
Hi, So nice to meet you!  -Nice to see you Buzzfeed. What's Trending?
So tell me what you're wearing tonight. -I'm wearing Burberry, from the House of Burberry.
So when did you get up this morning to get ready?
Uh.. I got up at about nine... had a nice breakfast.
...thought about playing tennis but there just wasn't enough time.
Who did your hair?  -I, uh, just you know, it just happens.  Heh, it's not a big deal.
What about mani-pedi's? show us your mani-pedi. -My What?!
Mani!!! Man, she is... did you start smoking before you came here today?
Have you been dieting for months, getting ready for this? -No, God no, oh absolutely not.
What about Spanx. Do you have any Spanx on tonight? -What.  Spanx? You know... to get it ready... to get it tight.
Man.  Buzzfeed is so f***** up. You guys are so f***** up.
-Good luck, enjoy your spanx.  Thank you!